انتهت اخر فصول الانتخابات التشريعيه في
تونس
واعلنت هيئه الانتخابات عن نسب المشاركه
في الدور الثاني ووصفتها بالضعيفه
حول عمل الهيئه خاصه فيما يتعلق بالنسب
والارقام التي
قدمتهام بالجنايات التي تدخل تحت طائره
القانون اذا كان عندك
للقضاء ولك الزد انك تتهم باطلا بدون
اثبات
القانون فوق الجميع جاءت نتائج الدور
الثاني للانتخابات النيابيه شبهها متطابقه
مع الدوري الاول حيث قطعتها الاحزاب
الرافده للاجراءات الاستثنائيه ومن بينها
جبهه الخلاص الوطني التي طرحت فرضيه تزوير
الانتخابات عبر رفع نسب المشاركه كما دعت
الى اجراء الانتخابات الرئاسيه وتشريعيه
مبكرا حوالي 90%
و89% من الشعب التونسي
اداره ظهره لهذه العامريه لهذه المسرحيه
ومره اخرى قال بانه لا ينخرط في هذا
المسلسل الانقلابي الذي لا يعنيه في شيء
وهو بذلك يعبر عن خيبه امل وعن سحب ثقه من
المسار الذي انطلق بانقلاب 25 جوليا يصير
الرئيس كيس سعيد على المضيق قدما في تشكيل
برلمان خال من الانتهازيه السياسيه ومن
الفاسدين على حد وصفهه متهم اطراف لم
يسميها بالعمل على افساد الدور الثاني
وخلق الفراغ واسقاط الدوله
وتزامنا مع المسار السياسي اطلق الاتحاد
العام التونسي والشغل سلسله اجتماعات مع
منظمات وطنيه اخرى تهدف الى صياغه مبادره
للحوار الوطني للخروج من الازمه السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه التي وصلت وفق
الاتحاد الى مرحله الخطر وانعدام رؤيه
حقيقيه للانقاذ في انتظار علينا النتائج
النهائيه للانتخابات التشريعيه يمضي
الرئيس قيس سعيد في تنفيذي خريطه الطريق
التي يعد هذه الانتخابات من مراحلها
المهمه في حين ترى اطراف المعارضه ان
الانتخابات تفتقد الشرعيه تونس